what does a show about an unorthodox
country girl babysitter taking care of
spoiled rich kids have in common with a
show about a teenage superhero
balancing his adventures with his
awkward social life both of them take
place in new york city
and i guess they aired on the same
channel sounds good enough for a
crossover to me
this review was requested by class act
media on patreon go donate it really
helps me out and check out my merch on
sale now
but before we talk about some super
heroic collaborations i want to thank
this video sponsor
surfsharkvpn what can i say about surf
shark well it's fast and easy to use
allowing you to connect to the server
that offers the best speed by default
it's just easy to install and can be
used on unlimited devices and plenty
more features beyond the basics
with surfshark you can watch shows and
style because it lets you bypass geo
restrictions to get the 15 largest
netflix libraries
and lets you access limited streaming
services like hulu and disney plus no
matter where in the world you are
you can even check out youtube videos
blocked in your country
your safety and security is also a top
priority by protecting your personal
data with uncrackable encryption
and the most secure vpn protocols
surfshark also provides ips and dns leak
protection so no one can track where
you're connecting from
and protects your data from being logged
this sounds like a good deal to you get
surfsharkvpn at the link in the
description and enter the promo code
godzilla for 83 percent off and three
extra months for free
who was this for why did this happen
there are obviously exceptions to the
rule but i assume the key demographics
for teen girl
sitcom and animated punchy superhero are
generally pretty [ __ ] different
was disney trying to reduce the gap by
getting the spider-man audience
interested in jessie and vice versa
if that was the goal then this crossover
special fails miserably
because honestly i don't think it's a
good representation of what either show
has to offer i'm in a very very very
very very very very very small minority
of people
who actually don't hate ultimate
spider-man i mean compared to what came
before it it's poopukaka but
on its own merit and with the context of
what they couldn't do
it has its moments the character designs
are cool the animation is pretty slick
still more or less understands
spider-man as a character when he's not
doing this weird ferris bueller [ __ ]
immature i know but it felt so good
and it tried something new introducing
obscure or underrated characters to new
viewers through the lens of a
lighthearted crossover i consider this
the brave and the bold of spidey
cartoons
and for whatever faults it has it's
certainly better than what came
after it all that being said
did you just slime me sorry but you got
in my way
in fact if you hadn't cut in line you
wouldn't be here in the first place i
hate drake bell's spider-man voice he
has zero range and delivers every line
exactly the same regardless of context
well
on the other hand jesse is uh
not really my thing i mean i was pretty
into zack and cody as a kid and even
caught the off episode of that's a raven
or hannah montana at 3am when nothing
else was on because i was homeschooled
and decided my own bedtime
i thought those shows were all right
even if i don't really care to revisit
them in my old age
i think jesse fits right along with that
if i was flipping channels late at night
youtube and netflix weren't a thing that
exists and i was bored out of my mind
i'd probably watch a few episodes back
to back in preparation for this review i
checked out the first episode and it
felt pretty standard for a disney sitcom
not every joke landed but every once in
a while got a chuckle out of me but i
can't
figure out why in god's name someone
decided these two needed to be mashed
together when it's such an
awkward and uncomfortable fit go do your
homework uh you're not the boss of me
actually i kind of am oh someone's about
to flip a table
this is in the same universe as galactus
jesse certainly isn't an action show by
any means nor is spider-man a situation
of comedy
all right all right let's actually talk
about the special itself well for some
reason spider-man and the cast of the
mick but for kids end up in a museum
late at night on halloween
random but okay the rambunctious chirons
accidentally dislodge a sword from one
of the exhibits and summon king arthur's
sister from the legend
morgan le faye is the sword king
arthur's sword
i don't know they never say morgan lefey
wants to take the sword for herself and
use it to take over the world
i seem to recall her motivation
involving a bit more incest but i guess
we'll just forget about that part
also her design was better in justice
league oh look another character
appearing in both marvel and dc things
we'll talk about that later so anyway
she makes all the exhibits in the museum
come to life and attack our heroes like
that ben stiller movie
until eventually they put the sword back
in and she disappears
or dies or whatever children
i just love children a few questions
immediately spring to mind about all
this
like why is jesse inexplicably a
swashbuckling sword fighting bad ass
is it are just people that are not from
the city like that
why am i not like that is the sword
making her do that is that just a thing
i didn't know about her from the show
since i only skimmed through one episode
why does the demon spell thing turn this
security guard into jack-o'-lantern i
guess maybe it's like an inverted
version of what happened to
jack-o'-lantern from the comics where he
took over the hobgoblin persona and
eventually made a deal with a demon
during the inferno event to get super
strength and demonic powers which
resulted in him splitting off into demo
goblin
no no it's just it's because he'd look
good as a villain in a halloween special
they didn't think about it that hard the
kids over here seem to all get some kind
of magic upgrade to their costumes from
the spell
but none of them do anything they just
stand around and quip while jesse and
spidey are doing all the fighting
you know i saw something similar on the
street in jaipur
but that involved cobras yeah but not
giant cobras right
no but go gross what was the joke here
he just repeated himself
what and lastly why is jesse such a
grouchy [ __ ] to spider-man
all he's doing is trying to help you
really have this under control
you sure you don't have any superpowers
i did okay didn't i
i guess not all heroes are super geez
don't break your arm patting yourself on
the back lady
she and the rest of the kids act like
they don't even know who he is how do
you move to new york city in this
universe and not at least hear something
about him
all in all it's ultimately pretty
innocuous and boring
it's not so terrible i hate it or
anything i just don't see any value in
it i feel like it was a bad idea
executed
badly the characters don't mesh well but
oddly enough cringy voice acting from
teen sitcom stars is not out of place in
this show
front-facing phineas front-facing
phineas it's my head cannon that this
other shameless crossover happened to
drake bell spider-man literally the next
day
you know this one feels a lot less
forced phineas and ferb mission marvel
is a better example of a crossover with
a non-superhero property because at
least all the basics are there to mesh
well
phineas and ferb have crazy impossible
adventures where your imagination is the
limit there's a hero there's a super
villain there's super science and
sometimes a battle against evil it's not
just a bunch of normal kids that hang
out in an apartment that looks like a
key lit
tv set all day phineas and ferb is a
show about two boys on summer vacation
who use their imagination and absurd
intellect to build just about anything
they want each day of the summer while
their older sister tries to gnark on
them
also randomly their pet platypus is a
secret agent and fights a mad scientist
for some b-plot action it's funny show
with a lot of heart but what put me off
to it as a kid is how repetitive the
episodes tend to be
they all sort of follow the same formula
and you know this crossover is no
exception
i suppose it's not a show you watch for
the plot it's just for the comedy and
the charm that comes from the single
plot they reuse
it's the house md of kids cartoons they
only got one episode for 10 seasons
straight
but it's a damn good episode in this
here animated adventure
an accident involving perry the platypus
as well as phineas and ferb's current
project accidentally de-powers a handful
of marvel heroes
hulk's strength is sapped spidey's webs
and stickiness don't work
thor can't lift his hammer despite his
worthiness and iron man's armor locks up
i'm a nitpick here a little cause he's
my favorite but spider-man's webs aren't
a power
nor an electronic device those should
still work but anyway
that creates a conflict where the heroes
can no longer take down a group of
villains including peter stormeira's
whiplash and danny trejo is venom what
random but
interesting casting so the avengers head
to phineas and ferb's house to ask for
some assistance in getting their powers
back
since that ray that zapped them
originated from a very distinct looking
satellite
there's a few gags in the middle with dr
doofenshmirtz hanging out with
bad guys the heroes getting their powers
swapped around like that fantastic four
movie no one saw
and then a big battle for the conclusion
i'm a nitpick here a little cause he's
my favorite but spider-man didn't need
the hulk's powers to do that he could do
that normally
be nice dear he's been studying abroad
really which broad
what's your name candace
[Music]
there's a lot of funny comedy bits here
and there that are really indicative of
the phineas and ferb sense of humor
and it was nice to hear something a
little more highbrow after
yes but cobras hey wait a minute there's
anything i really don't like about the
special is that the marvel heroes are an
extremely small part of it and the
phineas and ferb cast takes center stage
there's a lot of time devoted to this
conflict where the older sister candice
keeps trying to help out but makes
things worse and then gets yelled at for
it
then a long musical number about the
girls feeling excluded from superhero
fun times
[Music]
no who is really excluded from superhero
fun times the superheroes man spidey has
like less than 10 lines of dialogue in
this 40 minute thing
it's more like a standard phineas and
ferb episode featuring a bit
part by the avengers than in even half
and half which is fine i guess because
you know they stuck with what they do
best i also wish the heroes didn't spend
such a big chunk of the running time
powerless but i suppose there'd be no
story if they weren't nerfed
they just fly in and curb stomp faceless
nazi man in pal's ultimate alliance
style like they did at the beginning
it's not a bad crossover and it's got
both a lot of funny moments and
nice little marvel universe winks and
nods for the fanboys if you look close
i wouldn't exactly say it's required
viewing for any marvel fans but it's
still worth checking out if you'd
wondered what it would be like to see
these brands bump into each other a
little i wanted this list to be longer
and feature more bizarre crossovers
between superhero cartoons and
non-superheroes but frankly i was having
a hard time finding any more beyond
these two
honorable mention goes to the five
separate times batman and scooby-doo
have hung out
once is a full animated movie from the
70s oh my god velma's lips a short
follow-up episode of the scooby series
and then decades later in an anthology
episode of batman brave and the bold
hosted by batmite a show that's nothing
but crossovers this one is particularly
impressive because it's not even the
brave and the bold batman it's
specifically the one they already met in
the 70s again
this short segment is really cleverly
animated to mimic the limited character
movement
and lip-sync of the aged original
crossover also weird al is there
that's not really that out of place for
scooby-doo he's always hanging out with
celebrities the real icing on the cake
is that batmine is just as much of a
nerd as the rest of us and occasionally
comments on the animation errors and
even uses his powers to make things more
interesting
when this show was made batman couldn't
even throw a punch
lucky for us i possess near infinite
reality warping magical powers
holy [ __ ] he even allows shaggy to use
one percent of his power
what's even weirder is this brave and
the bold show came back after its
cancellation in 2011
seven years later that's pretty cool
considering this wasn't necessarily
anyone's favorite batman show
even though i think it's awesome and
getting these things revived
even temporarily is nearly impossible
now this time it's for sure the brave
and the bold batman
but he hasn't met the gang before so
they don't know each other
are these now separate timelines well
there goes my theory that every
scooby-doo thing is canon to the same
universe
eh that one makes sense anyway but yeah
i dig this one
in fact i'd say this is the best
crossover on the list here it has the
best action
it has a perfectly even balance of
scooby-doo and batman stuff and doesn't
feel forced
it also has the best writing because
there's so many moments that
legitimately made me laugh
what are you doing here i go wherever
puppet-related crime rears its ugly head
i don't want to spoil it a whole lot
because i think you should just
absolutely check this one out
my biggest takeaway from it was that
brave and the bold was underrated as
hell and i miss it dearly
i wish they'd do more occasional reunion
movies like this one
imagine every few years the bnb crew
comes back with aquaman
plastic man and dietrich bader's batman
for another random crossover could be
cool
but i have this feeling this is going to
be the last we see of this take on
batman
since no one was really begging for this
and its existence feels like a really
happy accident in the first place
but i'll go on record and say that i
want to see more of this series
all the other ones ran their course and
beware was underwhelming
if they ever revive a batman show full
stop this one is my pick
this special is fantastic go take a look
but let's say you don't care much for
the silver age love letter batman series
and prefer kevin conroy and mark
hamill's take on batman and the joker
all your cover too because in scooby-doo
and guess who
a show with a new cross over every
episode batman meets the gang again
three separate timelines of this it's a
multiversal constant
is this the dca you batman all the
character designs look pretty bruce
timmish
yo watchtower i'm asking you boys a
question whatever who cares it's a fun
episode
where darker batman and the gang both
solve the mystery of who kidnapped
alfred who has some kind of
spaceball's level of familial attachment
to daphne what are you doing here
how do you know alfred if you were on
your way here when you passed us
how did we get here first and where'd
you park the batmobile
i i batman's relegated to a bit part
while a pretty standard scooby episode
plays out with him occasionally jumping
in
it's not as good as the brave and the
bold one but it's still pretty funny and
worth checking out too
also i accidentally spoiled the mystery
already in this paragraph but maybe no
one noticed
you know now that i think about it
scooby-doo meets batman isn't that weird
of a crossover either since they both
tend to hang out with everyone else
you can trace everything back to
scooby-doo or batman at this point i'm
sure you could play some bizarre version
of six degrees of kevin bacon with the
amount of crossovers that have happened
over the years
like for example marvel zombies vs army
of darkness has ash williams pal around
with various marvel heroes and a
gruesome zombie tale but he's also been
at odds with freddy krueger and jason
voorhees and even
dark man jason voorhees is canonically a
dead
from the evil dead universe but both him
and freddie have fought each other
and the cast of mortal combat jason has
also met
leatherface of the texas chainsaw series
once before this
mortal kombat has crossed over with dc
as well as the predator and alien
xenomorph
who've crossed over with each other and
witchblade and the darkness
and even judge dredd who has met batman
a few times
jackie estacado of the darkness himself
has met batman superman
the hulk vampirella wolverine doctor
strange ghost writer and tomb raider in
his time too
and also batman superman and green
lantern have all had run-ins with the
predator and xenomorph
not to mention robocop and terminator
have battled before and once again in
the mortal kombat tournament
terminators also fought the alien and
the predator before himself
the predator has fought tarzan also
we're forgetting to mention that marvel
and dc have crossed over
multiple times with each other the x-men
have been beamed aboard the starship
enterprise and met kirk and spock
but star trek has also bumped into the
legion of superheroes in the future of
the dc universe
as well as the doctor from doctor who dc
has also
paired its heroes with the looney tunes
who have met with the disney animated
characters in roger rabbit
who have through the house of mouse met
all the characters of the various walt
disney movies like tarzan
whom i can only assume is the same one
who faced the predator
these disney princesses have also met
vanellope from wreck-it ralph
and her friend ralph is friends with
sonic bowser pac-man
who is actually friends with dig dug in
pac-man world and m bison
sonic and mario appear in the super
smash bros series as well as that one
time they competed in the olympics
which means their buddies with solid
snake and steve from minecraft
pac-man was in street fighter x tekken
speaking of street fighter a few of
those guys had encounters with marvel
characters in marvel vs capcom
which also included various resident
evil characters dante from dmc
and all these other guys dante's evil
twin brother dino dante name only
was also in playstation all-stars
alongside nathan drake
cole mcgrath isaac clark heihachi from
tekken
big daddy from bioshock and kratos
kratos has also been in the soul caliber
series which is in the past featured
darth vader
yoda starkiller link from zelda and
spawn
spawn kratos have also both fought in
the mortal kombat tournament
spawn is hung out with batman batman's
hung out with ninja turtles
ninja turtles were an injustice ninja
turtles also met the power rangers and
also the other ninja turtles who met the
other ninja turtles
one time the punisher mistook archie for
a crime boss and attempted to murder him
but archie has also been stalked by a
predator so he's used to this stuff
the punisher and eminem teamed up to
defeat barracuda we gotta remember
scooby doo
scooby doo is going on an adventure with
batman johnny bravo teen titans go
dean and sam of supernatural and the
harlem globetrotters who've also
appeared
in the little nikki and futurama series
which has gone back in time to meet the
simpsons the simpsons of course have had
cameos from king of the hill the critic
the x-files 24
and then family guy everything is
connected to everything
everything is in the same universe
[Music]
you